the bella russian people
are not giving up this is the fourth
sunday in a row that they've come out
around 100 000 again on the streets of
minsk
in the rain outside the presidential
palace
chanting we don't forget and we don't
forgive
and calling for their president to face
a tribunal
they want him to be held to account for
this the ongoing and unnecessary
police brutality at least a hundred
people detained in minsk this sunday
according to the interior ministry this
week with term beginning it was students
especially who were targeted
even picked up from inside their
university halls
but it's not going to stop 23 year old
alexander redchenko from going out
lukashenka thinks that
he is able to take the government
and all the people under his conditions
but that's not the case right now
because our country is a different
country after
these elections we are different people
right now
73 year old nina baginskaya started
picketing back in the 90s
to protest closer integration with
russia always with the red and white
flag
the national flag for four years after
belarus gained independence
and the soviet union was breaking up
racism
russia had imperial aspirations and
never wanted belarus to be free
she has become an inspiration to the
crowds fated when she shows up
find half her pension for carrying the
flag but not afraid to fight for it
i grabbed the pole and the flag and
began pulling back with all my might
in the end he snatched the flag back but
before that
i kicked him with my foot and though i
am an old woman
and my kick wasn't a strong one it was
an insult
for him
[Applause]
this week masked men in green uniforms
with no insignia showed up at the
protests
it's not clear who they are and they may
well be part of the belarusian security
apparatus
but the symbolism of little green men is
uncomfortable for anyone nervous about
russian
involvement lukashenko will travel cap
in hand to moscow soon
for all the strong man posturing he is
desperate and the kremlin
knows how to exploit that
dynamic sky news moscow